fallout continues after news came out
this week that an iconic downtown
property and wedding venue is set to be
demolished sasha lofta spoke with one
woman tonight who says this news came
out of nowhere and she's had to scramble
to switch gears
christian this is the second bride this
week that's come to us frustrated about
this news regarding the heartland
mansion now she says in this case she's
lost a lot of money
but it's just been very frustrating
larissa gaccione describes what she
calls an awful experience while planning
her wedding we kind of just were at this
point like i guess we call it a loss and
start over she says she and her fiance
were set to get married at mansion 54
also known as heartland mansion downtown
but about a month ago everything changed
all of a sudden this veil was lifted and
now all these things are coming out and
it wasn't communicated larissa says she
got an email saying the iconic property
sold and would no longer be holding
events she tells us the couple only got
a portion of their money back we've lost
now over 5 thousand dollars because we
have had a separate caterer scheduled
earlier this week city and fire
officials confirmed the historic site is
now set to be demolished at the new
owner's request that i can't even
imagine for the brides who were that
month or this month
and the money they've lost in the end
larissa was able to rebook her big day
but she says this kind of emotional and
financial stress has been anything but
easy we spent a lot of time and energy
on even trying to get everything reset
come out more out of pocket
[Music]
now i reached out to larissa's contact
with mansion 54 but have not heard back
in time for this newscast 8 news now
also reached out to the new property
owner this week but have not received a
response reporting live downtown tonight
sasha loftis live local now